bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france alors
donc cette nouvelle taxe américaine sur
le vin les pièces aéronautiques entre en
vigueur à demain ce mardi plutôt
concrètement qu'est ce que cela change
sur le plan économique pour les deux
parties c'est bien vous savez les états
unis ont obtenu le droit de taxer 7,5
milliards de produits européens pour
compenser les subventions que l'europe
fait à airbus
les etats unis ont estimé que jusqu'à
présent il n'avait pas atteint 17,5
milliards de produits taxés et donc ils
ont décidé de taxer en plus les pièces
détachées de de l'aéronautique
les vins en vrac et le cognac l'armagnac
palais les alcools forts donc n'a plus
la conséquence c'est d'un côté de
renforcer en quelque sorte la position
de boeing
par rapport à un bus sur le marché
américain et surtout d'introduire des
pénalités pour les viticulteurs
européens puisque la stratégie dans
danser d'antan dans la matière
ça consiste à taxer un secteur pour que
ce secteur
sa suppression sur son gouvernement pour
que le gouvernement change de position
sur d'autres questions de politique
économique
en quelque sorte les viticulteurs sont
pris en otage 11 une dans un débat qui
concerne principalement les relations
entre airbus et boeing
est ce que il faut craindre pour sa
viticulture justement les conséquences
aux fêtes attacks naturellement nos
conséquences de cette taxe c'est une
baisse de la de leurs jantes aux états
unis donc ça touchant les vins français
et cette chose dit le corps
ac l'armagnac peut-être ça tous plus
d'ailleurs les alcools forts que les
vins français est donc naturellement ça
va occasionner des pertes assez ces
producteurs qui s'ajoute en quelque
sorte au fait une paire et de fait de la
crise du col vide
il ya un certain nombre et d'importation
vers les produits et des vers les pays
asiatiques qui sont hockey sur glace
disait que les viticulteurs se retrouver
en position justement d'otages justement
est ce qu est ce qu on pouvait éviter
cette taxe qui fait suite à un litige
entre américains et européens
j'en sais c'est la règle du jeu
malheureusement les états unis et
l'europe se dispute sur les subventions
que hilal qui font mutuellement et en
plus sous android
c'est particulièrement ridicule
actuellement parce qu'on est
ce sont deux entreprises qui sont en
difficulté du fait de la crise des
acolytes qui toute façon vont être
aidées par le gouvernement et donc on
traîne ses affaires judiciaires devant
l'om c'est chacun chaque pays chaque
parti accuse l'autre de tropez d'échouer
en bus warwick et donc c'est c'est la
règle du jeu quelque sorte de l'om sait
où on autorise un pays à prendre des
mesures de représailles contre un autre
et ça peut apparaître tout à fait tout à
fait injuste de taxer les viticulteurs
tour une affaire aéronautique mais il
faut dire que nous aurons que l'europe
fait pareil et on taxe les produits
américains en représailles des
subventions à boeing
l'état français qui a annoncé vouloir
venir en aide
aux viticulteurs alors qu'on sait que le
contexte était quand même déjà compliqué
est-ce que ça va vraiment être possible
d'aider un les eti cult'art vous savez
actuellement on est dans une doctrine
quoi qu'il en coûte de feydeau que on va
aider les on va aider les viticulteurs
si effectivement sont particulièrement
frappés par cette mesure
il faut pas non plus exagérer la portée
de la mesure à le les pertes sont de
l'ordre d'un milliard d'euros
si on tient compte de l'ensemble des
taxes américaines sur les idées va donc
on a ainsi un ordre de grandeur d'un
média qu'il va falloir vers c'est
peut-être à ce secteur qui en difficulté
en raison de 2,7 de cet acte mettait
aussi en difficulté en raison de la
fermeture des ddt restaurant qui
également fait sur demande sur l'ailé de
l'afld est également delà de la
disparition des deux événements festifs
ou culturels qui pèsent également sur la
vente
donc notez cependant que le champagne
épargné il avait été question de mettre
une forte taxe sur le champagne pour
compenser la taxe que la france mais sur
les gaffes à les états unis le 6 janvier
on renonce évolué armes en attaque c'est
le champagne est donc le champagne est
déjà actuellement à cette taxation
le champagne comme l'ensemble des vins
pétillants la taxation porte uniquement
sur ce qu'on appelle les vins
tranquilles
ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle henri
sterdyniak peut-être une lueur d'espoir
vous allez nous dire puisqu'on est à
huit jours de l'investiture de joe biden
est ce que la donne peut changer
après cette date il faut distinguer deux
dossiers il ya un premier dossier qui
est le dossier de la taxation des
cafards la france va taxer les gaffes à
cette année il avait été question que
les états unis prennent des mesures de
rétorsion contre la france sur le
champagne des fromages les sacs à main
et les produits de beauté
jusqu'à présent cette mesure n'a pas été
mis en oeuvre dont peu ont une partie
des taxes qui devait être mis en oeuvre
le 6 janvier qui n'ont pas arrêté donc
dans le cas de la négociation sur la
taxation des gars pas par contre 7
cette taxe qui va être introduit à
partir d'aujourd'hui elle découle de
d'une victoire juridique si on peut dire
des états unis contre l'europe au à l'om
sait et il est peu probable que joe
biden revienne là-dessus avant d'une
grande négociation qui peut espérer
quand même qui un jour une grande
négociation entre l'europe et les états
unis pour avoir un armistice et que les
deux pays reconnaissent que
effectivement il subventionne tous les
deux et en bus héloïse et qu' ils
admettent tous les deux merci beaucoup à
vous et henri sterdyniak
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste à
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques et membre des économistes
atterrés